peloton comme en moins
quoi jacquet
zollikofen tout toussaint public au
repos et reprendre la vallée devant nous
on va prendre la balle et on va
descendre dans plutôt en phase de mou
tout à l'heure un peu tout mettre en
valeur un attrait plus réduit et
franchement utilisable à tout croire
regarde il regarde éventuellement dont
on retiendra comme mr aulas va faire
quelque chose de sa non mais c'est pas
la peine de le voilà voilà je sais
trouble aux abords de chaque fois qu'on
n'arrivait cycle dans la cascade les
belles du banc et parental est très mal
de casque a passé la cascade elle est
belle parce que les ailes pas convaincu
elle s'étale vachement doigt les vaches
grandeur on va on va le regretter qu'ils
chantent récurrents avoir trahi par le
franc est content de ta hockey vers le
bas
j'aime bien entre eux je l'espère quand
je suis allé parce que
planete - mcewen nouveaux solistes tu
veux quand ils sont le trou tu veux
qu'on passe quoi elle aussi en deçà des
espèces de polio fottorino de stormy
weather back with aucun sont pas tous du
galop pas 3 3 12e speed tout prix de la
pentecôte ou bonne bouille sillage le
voile sur la tête là on la voit ce rôle
historique dans l'histoire il doit venir
d'en haut comme quoi avec logique en
playback
ok ok ben ali et barbie respect dans le
hockey parce que ça m'étonnait dans le
vent un vainqueur à nice coule au soleil
travailler dessus bakou
encore un peu le paysage quand même tu
vas voir quoi puis on en a lancé ce qu'a
fait la droite à mon avis la plus le
côté et en prend bien le détail des
couleurs un peu quand ça sort c'est
assez vite acculèrent je vous prierais
maintenant j'ouvrirai pouvoir la
montagne derrière c'est assez beau clos
lolo c'est assez vite à la montagne je
voudrais vers la droite
je brûlais vers la droite le zoom dézoom
vers la droite ou vers la droite
la montagne c'est vachement pau va leur
faire sa route la montagne qui arrive
parce que c'était très beau parce que tu
es tu descendras vers la plus vers la
plus jolie endroit en fin de compte le
pet l'endroit c'est d'aller d'aller vers
nous c'est à dire de revenir de zoomer
vers l'hélicoptère
si tu m'expliques bien de zoom en
descendant vers le passé super poussins
des peleurs d'ail 1 veut voir les deux
noirs c'est sublime
voilà comme ça en blanc berdou voilà
voilà voilà sept fallait encore que ce
qu'on regarde que c'est beau si à tomber
se regarde regarde pour bell de deux
couleurs dans tous les sens parce que
c'est poser un regard pour
magique voilà et c'est aussi très beau
si tu vas tu es si tu vas un peu verte à
droite on voit monter un peu vers la
droite en hauteur et taches noires sans
oublier sens mais en montant ce que tu
es là j'ai goûté truc là à droite c'est
un peu plus vers la droite et tu
remontes vers le haut vous montreront
très les trous en latéral du noir voilà
le pari de dans le coeur des taches
noires est pas bien hauteur et c'est
exactement derrière ça voilà regarde
regarde les taches noires voire l'iran
doit toi espèce de tache noire qui a
deux espèces de carhaix en croit une
croix noire sur la neige
ah oui il est en train c'est super beau
ça or battus en rade sud et ils vous
emmènent 2 sur ps2 graphisme inouïe
alors voilà même si tu peux
des zooms bain et tu vas vers vers la
sphère magogois comme ça voilà on va
passer à côté de la grande montagne
clairet tout à l'heure voilà voilà comme
ça voilà des zooms et tuba mer vers
l'avant des dicos eisenia doucement
doucement doucement
voilà même allé devant l'hélicoptère thd
et de neige qui j'ai eu devant nous la
charge pas au petit déj paquet devant le
bâtiment
voilà tu es devant donc voilà c'est
génial comme ça reste comme ça que le
noir à gauche voilà le noir à gauche
3 parce que ses poulains regarde et que
nous vos fins coquet on arrive sur le go
on va on va kendrick au faste biscopem
ok ok on va aller assez vite
la droite au québec
elle décore les enfants regardent ça
regarde la couleur chair regarde ça mais
c'est inouï
on à l'arrière sont les couleurs vocales
en arrivant plus eu peur on avait tout à
l'heure ça passe à côté de leur amour au
cube la tombe est ce qu'on appelle un
intérêt qu'un tremblement temps dieu
michel explique l'ingénieur tête à
[ __ ] on amène la géotechnique c'est
pourquoi que ça et en rachats d ici cet
accord est lui aussi donné que constater
la grande surface droite de la perte de
revoir les couleurs dans la vallée la
droite hélicoptères on arrive dessus
attention bien at on va arrive dessus de
ça dans une vallée là maintenant un peu
plus trop dresde ont tourné court à
brest entre uccle remonte vers l'avant
voilà c'est la balle est qu'est la baie
de suspense voilà regarde ça regarde
raté dessus la voilà dans le noir hier
que ces pauses tiens ici à tomber ça et
qui se mélangent et en plus on a de la
neige à la même le mélange des ombres et
du soleil en barrières non pas comme
c'est beau en bas de la montagne noire
on a filmé tout à l'heure ça tout ça
avec le soleil tu pu passer très très
beau avec la coulée de largeur arabes
montrent à gauche montag bagosora la
coulée de lave sur la montagne va à
gauche à gauche tout voilà coulées de
lave à gauche bras gauche va voir dessus
encore encore à gauche encore à gauche
vas-y vas-y vas-y
voilà voir dans l'arrêt de sio n'arrête
de sullens je vois plus rien j'ai à
gauche bourges gauche bourges couche
bah tu la vois tu la coulée de lave la
norme voila voila on exclut là je pense
non à leur nez dessus le point un petit
peu de colère va pas bien ok tu sors la
blessure la lave
ok yassa 6 juillet et là on descend soir
là maintenant on descend dessus on prend
pas tourner à gauche si on va sur la
lave
c'est pas parce qu'un coq l'os ou à la
main tout cela vaincre mairie klaus tout
cela vas y mollo est pour toi ça c'est
magique
voilà klaus ou de l'avant voilà la
regarde sa cible
je mets des zigs maffre m tassez vous de
likouala eu la regarde les couleurs
aussi des épées des arbres ddpp des gens
qui finissent sur les sur la montagne
qui est derrière et doivent bien à
droite de la droite de la lave toi
les montagnes qui sont tellement belles
en masse de ces terrains gelés fait rare
le camp le programme est belle quand et
pas mal entendants vers cette montagne
noire modèle berck et devant qui à
l'ombre sur un manteau vert peut-être
chemin j'ai dû insister parce que c'est
beau la droite regarde story
ok mylène ouellette eba basile ader ben
non c'est pas parce que j'étais beau
sapin avec
[ __ ] bon bon bon petit en guerre bon
ok bon gouvernement de son pays à la
route que devant qui est pas très belle
quand même ce gage tout la route se
prépare dans la tendance est quand même
pas mal
il roule intérieur malades et à la fin
cela incite à revenir au corps
wen avait pas d'autre moyen touchante
cratère drame un retour de saint vianney
d'euros ils sont gelés
oui oui un briquet magnifique est
attendu en recul - il a raison regarde à
droite bas droite droite voyaient la
laddh qui descendront c'est vachement
poutine verra à la droite de michel il
va voir michel on va passer en vertical
au dessus un club face à droite ou à
gauche
malheureusement il la neige sur le
dessin assez con c'est un truc
rappel du toit au-dessus on passe
verticale à gauche cela risque de ne pas
faire en vertical tu es plutôt de passer
en contre jour non ok super pour hurler
de rire le d5 ça c'est sublime ça ouais
mais bon dans l'espèce de ses pouces que
tout sur la gauche ça va ça va je m'en
souviens de ce truc là j'avais presque
superposent de l'asean
de quoi petit crochet étouffant du doigt
pour être au toit toutes les vérités sur
le rocher ses vaches un ragot j'ai un
peu la donne superbe
le lavage regarde le bâton mais celui-là
la matière quat'sous dinan d'autant que
londres
on m'a dit tu es bien le sait plus qui
de l'abonnement si toi tu as coupé a
surpris un peu lente et laborieuse
auquel nous comptons contre jour david
un autre joueur en tout cas cette marque
les battues va plus en avoir tendance à
dos après donc tu va couper hacher trop
vertical à charlesbourg et docteur maria
regarde comme c'est pour le prendre
comme en le jouant vite on va tourner
vers la gauche pour avoir en contre jour
buteur boulonnais championne est venue
en europe
un recul qui s'écarte un peu par la
suite
adacore ouais enfin drôle du tout
pas de droit à leur plus fort dans la
vie droit à 80 ans l'ont enfin qu aux
lions et les hyènes droite parti bien
c'est pas mal ça va il valait vers la
gauche où il va les gars les vélib les
berlugans françois plus besoin de rêver
aux jeux là bas vers la gauche voit ses
peaux mates à gauche tanguy gauche
genevoise est pas j'aurais peut-être pu
serrer sachets page avait poussé dedans
qu'est ce t'en penses je vais soutenir
une guerrière que la lave derrière tu as
tout la barre où il y aurait un bon
ballon à droite et plus tolérer droite
voilà tous vers la droite que la gauche
la gauche c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
je suppose voilà compris vers la côte et
s'embrasser
c'est magnifique bravo tu en dis bravo à
ces magnifiques hockey
quand j'y pense
ça c'est rigolo en tout cas ok
maintenant on va faire le labc et deux
grandes ou alors la faune va sortir et
les go fast bateau on va faire
l'intérieur
derrière les deux premiers colons est un
terrible c'est qu'on peut arriver dessus
et pour préparer leurs emprunts ok c'est
bien qu'ils donnent cavale lettres et
julien l'a perdue là le pq pgo année
section parce que
regarde le gard montre que je vais bien
à droite voire droite bas droite tandis
qu'à droite on en parlera à droite un
droit d'encore regarde toi regarde la
descente au lowe's est magnifique ça
bouge dans un beau jeu dans là dessus
beaucoup de couches dessus absolument
nous a dit vas-y fais leur bougeant un
peu bavarde rouge à droite gauche on
descendra du sol pour les premiers
blancs rouges et qu'elle le ferait mais
je voudrais un peu plus angers découvrir
et non pas tant d'avoir passé la voiture
peut pas le découvrir
on est passé le volcan là pour ça il va
plus me lever de soleil moite pas bouger
tant la tap a bougé un pull droite à
gauche tout simplement
salah
ladite descendre des 100kg dit attendre
elle relève éric hoziel this way back
and go to the tender night wedding
il faut faire le kiwi km